Kate Hudson and boyfriend Danny Fujikawa
pack on the PDA a 38 year old actress
and her musician beau were spotted
sharing a post-workout smooch on
Saturday
Kate rocked a white tank leggings and
Sonny's for the sweat sesh while Danny
wore grey shorts a black tee and
matching shades the pair who made their
official red carpet debut as a couple at
the snatch premiere in May 2017 seemed
to be stronger than ever
Kate and Danny just celebrated one year
of dating and on the anniversary of
their quote unexpected first date Kate
shared this kiss he picked to Instagram
revealing they first met when she was 23
and pregnant with her first son Ryder
she gushed in the caption on her 15th
year of knowing each other we were able
to open our hearts to each other to feel
so much pure love and it's been truly
incredible hashtag love this man a sign
it's meant to be Kate's parents Goldie
Hawn and Kurt Russell approved that he's
a nice guy yeah yeah yeah he's very
special
[Music]
you